Hey, welcome to smartlist. Oh, really good, dude. Really original. Where'd you come up with that? Do you write that? I figured somebody's got to kind of start it, and then something funny will come afterwards from you, too. Happy to start again. Hey, welcome to smartlist. Oh, it's the exact same thing that you did the first time. But I put six S's on that one. Oh, hey there, listener. Welcome to smartlist. I'm your co-host, Jason Bateman, along with Canada's own Will Arnett and Wisconsin native. Oh, fuck, I wish I could fire you. I wish I could fire you from this job. Wait, still rolling, still rolling. Welcome to smartlist. This is a podcast, and we are- Honestly, dude, just say welcome to smartlist. Here we go.
嘿，欢迎收看 SmartLess。哦，真棒，老兄。太有创意了。你是从哪想出来的？这台词是你写的吗？我想总得有人先起个头，然后你就会接着抖出好笑的包袱。很高兴能再来一次。嘿，欢迎收看 SmartLess。哦，这跟你刚才做的一模一样。不过我在那个上面加了六个 S。哦，嘿，听众朋友们。欢迎收看 SmartLess。我是你们的联合主持人杰森·贝特曼，还有来自加拿大的威尔·阿奈特以及威斯康星州本地人。哦，他妈的，我真想炒了你。我真想把你从这份工作里开除。等等，还在录，还在录。欢迎收看 SmartLess。这是一个播客，我们正——说实话，老兄，直接说“欢迎收看 SmartLess”就行了。我们开始吧。
Good morning, fellas. Did you have breakfast this morning? Are you breakfast guys? I don't need to later. I'm getting a little tired of my oatmeal regimen, and I'm wondering what I could kind of maybe pivot to. You have it everywhere, right? Like, no matter where you go, you take that. Like, if you had a man to go down, let's say you were to go on vacation, you go to Mexico with the kids. Yeah. Do you- Well, I'm not taking oatmeal with me. You're not taking oatmeal across. You're not mulling oatmeal across the Mexican border. No, no, no. They got oatmeal all over the place. The problem is that, you know, I'm a little slightly gluten-sensitive, so, you know, if they don't have gluten-free
早啊，伙计们。你们今天吃早餐了吗？你们是那种爱吃早餐的人吗？我待会儿不需要。我对我那套燕麦片食谱有点腻了，我在想自己是不是该换换口味了。你到处都吃得到，对吧？不管你去哪，你都带着它。比如说，如果你要带家人出游，比方说你要去度假，带着孩子们去墨西哥。对。你——好吧，我可不会把燕麦片随身带去。你总不会把燕麦片带过——你总不会把燕麦片偷运过墨西哥边境吧。不不不，他们到处都有卖燕麦片的。问题是，你知道的，我稍微有点对谷蛋白轻度过敏，所以，你知道的，如果他们没有无麸质的……
so then I have to pivot to something different, and I'm wondering- I'm telling you right now, every day, yogurt with fruit in it and grape nuts. That's what I eat. Grape nuts. Grape nuts. Now, see, that would wreck my teeth. And this is what you use the time machine, and you jump back to 1981, grab the grape nuts, and they came back. What a dumb usage of a time machine. You bought a truck full of grape nuts. That's where they all went. Yeah. Wait, why do they hurt your teeth? Because they're nuts. Yeah. They're like ball bearings unless they've been in milk for about a day and a half.
那我只好换吃别的了，我在想——我跟你直说吧，我每天都吃加水果和葡萄干麦仁的酸奶。我就吃这个。葡萄干麦仁。葡萄干麦仁。你看，那会毁了我的牙齿。这就是你得用时光机跳回 1981 年，抓一把葡萄干麦仁，然后再带回来的原因。多蠢的时光机用法啊。你买了一卡车葡萄干麦仁。原来它们都被你买光了。对。等等，为什么它们会伤牙齿？因为它们是麦仁啊。对。它们就像滚珠轴承一样硬，除非在牛奶里泡个一天半半。
Oh, God. Like your brain. But you still eat them? What about alpin? Did you ever eat alpin? No, granddad. It's like a loosely- God. What about a nice- Oh, you know what I found out from my doctor the other day is that eggs, eggs do not give you cholesterol. They don't- I heard this. Yeah, eggs are- That's a whole wives' tale or whatever. It's, you're good to go with eggs, yolks included. They call it a partner's tale now. Thanks very much. What? They don't call it a wives' tale. They call it a partner's tale.
哦，天哪。就像你的大脑一样。但你还是吃它们？那阿尔卑斯麦片呢？你吃过阿尔卑斯麦片吗？没有，老爷爷。那感觉就像一颗松散的——天哪。那来点好的——哦，你知道我前几天从医生那里了解到什么吗？鸡蛋，鸡蛋不会导致胆固醇升高。它们不——我听说过这个。对，鸡蛋是——那完全是老妻少妻的无稽之谈什么的。对，吃鸡蛋完全没问题，连蛋黄一起吃。他们现在管这叫伴侣的无稽之谈。非常感谢。什么？他们不叫老妻的无稽之谈。他们叫伴侣的无稽之谈。
Oh, God. So fuck off. Okay. You know, anyway, eggs don't give you cholesterol anymore. They used to, but they don't now. Yeah. That's what Jason just said. Yeah. You don't need to re-say it. They got it. No, I'm just saying. But you said it like you owned it. Like you just owned that idea. Yeah, like it was some new idea. You just had it. But Jason just already said that. You said it like it was a brand new thought. Yeah. So we're in a four-wheel slide. We're in a four-wheel slide.
哦，天哪。所以滚蛋吧。好吧。总之，不管怎样，鸡蛋现在不会让你胆固醇升高了。过去会，但现在不会了。对。杰森刚才不就这么说的嘛。对。你不用再复述一遍了。他们都懂。不，我只是说说而已。但你那语气听起来就像是你的原创观点。就像那主意是你刚想出来的一样。对，就像那是个什么新点子。你刚刚才想出来的。但杰森刚才已经说过了。你说话的语气听得好像那是你全新的想法。对。所以我们现在失控了，车子在滑向路边。我们现在车子彻底失控了。
We're leaving the highway right now. I know I have so many thoughts of like stuff that I wanted to say. Oh, let's hear them. Well, no. Any more partner's tales? It's not worth it. Anyway, you know, anyway, that's neither here nor there, but it's kind of everywhere. And more importantly, our guest right now, unbelievable. You guys know this person. This person I once described as Hollywood's least favorite Greek. It's because of Jan and Clooney. There's so many other people ahead of this person. This person, I also once asked on stage why they decided to get into show business.
我们现在正冲出高速公路。我知道我脑子里有很多想说的话。哦，说来听听。好吧，不用了。还有什么伴侣的无稽之谈吗？不值得。总之，你知道的，反正这事虽说跟这儿没太大关系，但好像哪儿都有它。更重要的是，我们现在的嘉宾，简直不可思议。你们都认识这个人。我曾经把这个人形容为好莱坞最不受欢迎的希腊人。这是因为有简和克鲁尼。排在这个人前面的大腕可太多了。这个人，我还曾在舞台上问过他为什么决定进演艺圈。
And I can't remember his answer, but this is a person who never stops making me laugh until he does. Oh, wait. I know who this is. Oh, my God. I hope this is who I think it is. I love hate and you guys know, and in America, adores, even though he lives in Canada, please give it up for the one, the only Mr. Zach Galifianak. Oh, boy. What a land there. There he is. Look at him. Hi, everybody. Hi, guys.
我不记得他的回答是什么了，但这个人总是能让我笑个不停，直到他停下来。哦，等等。我知道这是谁了。哦，天哪。我希望这正是我心里想的那个人。我爱恨交织，你们也都知道，美国人都崇拜他，尽管他住在加拿大，请把掌声送给独一无二的扎克·加利费安纳基斯先生。哦，天哪。这下子降落得可真够精彩的。他来了。快看他。大家好。嗨，伙计们。
Well, I was praying that you were going to land this fish at some point. I'm just, I'm a real fan, Zach. I'm just going to be quiet and fan out while these guys ask questions. By the way, I apologize for the guest, the guest let down of the special guest let down. I could already see the buyers remorse in your faces. I was hoping I thought it was going to be Jimmy the Greek. And then I was like, no, I think he's dead. No, he's canceled. No, I, Zach, I don't know you probably as well as these guys do, but I do. We have met many times and you're always so pleasant. And I've been a such a fan for such a long
好吧，我刚才一直在祈祷你总算能把这条大鱼给钓上来。我只是，我是你的死忠粉，扎克。我就安静地当个小迷弟，让这几位来问问题吧。顺便说一句，对于这个特邀嘉宾的让人失望，我深表歉意，特邀嘉宾的这种拉胯表现。我已经在你们脸上看到买家悔恨的表情了。我本来还以为会是“希腊人吉米”呢。然后我想了想，不对，他好像已经死了。不，他是被取消了。不，我，扎克，我对你的了解可能不如这几位那么深，但我确实了解。我们见过很多次面，你总是那么随和。而且我一直是你的超级粉丝。
time. Sean, I remember meeting you for the first time. I was doing some terrible bit at a Luna Park. I think I was doing something on stage where it was a, remember that show, the real world? Of course. Sure. I used to watch it all the time. I used to do the real world with just one person in it. And I performed, I performed it live
肖恩，我还记得我们第一次见面。当时我在月神公园（Luna Park）表演某个糟糕的段子。我想我当时在台上做了一件事，还记得那个节目《真实世界》（The Real World）吗？当然。当然记得。我以前经常看。我以前在里面只安排了一个人来重现《真实世界》。而且我是现场表演的。
on stage. It made no sense. And you were at that show and you were very nice to me after that. Oh yeah. I remember that. Yeah, that was hilarious. Wait, I have a question about you being an actor, Zach. Were you ever the type of actor who had some kind of like trajectory in mind for your career and then got sideswiped by like the hangover or something where you go, Oh, I thought it was going to do a talk show
在舞台上。简直莫名其妙。你当时就在那场演出里，演出结束后你对人非常好。哦，对。我记得。对，太搞笑了。等等，我有关于你作为演员的问题，扎克宿醉之类的，让你觉得，哦，我本打算去做个脱口秀。
or a standup or a one hour drama, but I guess I'm a movie star now. A Shakespearean actor. Well, yeah, I mean, you're right, Bateman. I did get my start in the London Academy of Dramatic Arts. Is that what it's called? Yeah. And then you went on and you did the real world two-hander at Luna Park and it all went to shit. I played La Crosse at Juilliard with nobody didn't get spotted. Well, no, I think, I think Sean's onto something here. You know, you look, listener, if you
还是单口喜剧，或者一小时的正剧，但我想我现在是个电影明星了。莎士比亚演员。好吧，对，你是对的，贝特曼。我的确是从伦敦戏剧艺术学院出道的。是叫这个名字吗？对。然后你接着去月神公园演了那个单人版《真实世界》，结果一切都搞砸了。我在茱莉亚学院打过长曲棍球，没人注意到我。好吧，不，我觉得，我觉得肖恩说得有道理。你看，听众朋友们，如果你。
could see the tableau we're looking at, it really does look like he's, he's doing nature hike, running a nature hike business. Is this where, I mean, it looks like you're kind of living the dream. You've sort of, you've staked your claim to Hollywood. You have one and then you said, guess what, honey, we're going to go ahead, we're going to buy an island question mark in British Columbia and just go ahead and take the victory and, and hit fuck it. Well, my wife is Canadian and I've lived on and off in Canada for years, even before I knew her. And I really do like it up here. And they've kind of rejected Will and Bateman,
能看到我们现在看到的画面，他看起来真的很像在进行一次户外徒步，经营着一家户外徒步公司。这里是——我的意思是，你看上去就像在过着梦想中的生活。你算是在好莱坞占领了一席之地。你成功了，然后你说，猜怎么着，亲爱的，我们要继续前行，我们要去买下不列颠哥伦比亚省的一个问号岛，然后直接享受胜利，管他妈的。好吧，我太太是加拿大人，我多年来一直断断续续地住在加拿大，甚至在认识她之前就住过。我真的很喜欢这里。他们有点排斥威尔和贝特曼。
aren't you Canadian? How dare you? No, I, no, I've spent time there though and I've enjoyed it. I have enjoyed it up there. He does look like he's got like a, like a backpack and he's, and he's taking sticky BCB to weed across the border, like into Washington state. Are you mule? Is there marijuana here? Higher, higher Zach.
难道你不是加拿大人吗？你怎么敢这么说！不，我，不，我在那儿待过，我很享受。我在那儿过得很开心。他看起来确实像背着个背包，然后他正带着优质的 BC 省大麻过境，运到华盛顿州去。你是偷运客吗？这里有大麻吗？高一点，再高一点，扎克。
Do you put a couple more question marks in that pitch? No, but you look like, I mean, you're living the dream. I'm so envious. Look at you. Just not washed the hair super long. You're in a happy marriage, which I am enjoying here. Some people say that I look like a Jodie Foster with a beard. Who's been saying that? Who's been saying that? Just mostly people online. You mean when she was with Matthew McConaughey? I'm always tracking my Twitter stuff.
你在那个语气里多加几个问号行吗？不，但你看起来，我的意思是，你在过着梦想中的生活。我太嫉妒了。看看你。头发没洗，留得超长。你婚姻幸福，我很享受这个。有人说我看起来像留着胡子的朱迪·福斯特。谁说的？这话是谁说的？基本上都是网上的人。你是说她和马修·麦康纳在一起的时候吗？我一直在关注我的推特动态。
Do you, do you, first of all, what do you miss most? Like you, you did all those, you did all those movies, all those hangover movies. Oh, I've done so many projects over the years. So many projects. What do you miss most about not, because you're not working with Bradley anymore? Is it the paparazzi? Hmm. Well, listen, I see, you know, it's tough to get popped all the time, isn't it? Oh man, those paps, those paps with the pops. Is the paparazzi still a thing?
你，你，首先，你最怀念什么？就像你，你拍了所有那些电影，所有那些《宿醉》电影。哦，这些年来我拍了太多项目了。太多的项目了。因为你不再和布莱德利合作了，你最怀念的是什么？是狗仔队吗？嗯。好吧，听着，你看，一直被偷拍挺不容易的，对吧？哦，天哪，那些狗仔队，带着相机狂拍的狗仔队。狗仔队现在还存在吗？
No, because of the, because of COVID and the masks and everything, they, these guys have had to find real work. Huh. Let me ask you this. So Zach, so... I liked my question before about the actor. Well, I know I was going to say the same thing, which I was, something that was Sean was saying. So you come out of North Carolina, all bits aside. No, it's good. Serious. What was the thing? So you moved, you were, you moved to New York with, is that right?
没有了，因为疫情、口罩和各种原因，这些家伙不得不去找真正的工作了。嗯。我问你个问题。所以，扎克，所以……我还是喜欢我刚才关于演员的那个问题。好吧，我知道我正要说同样的话，也就是肖恩刚才说的事抛开所有的段子不谈，你来自北卡罗来纳州。不，这很好。认真的。那到底是怎么回事？所以你搬去了，你是，你搬去纽约了，是这样吗？
You moved with Miles and Bobby Tisdale. Is that how that went down? And you moved to New York to become a standup originally, just a standup or an actor? No, I moved to New York to try to get into acting and, you know, you read those stories about, oh, I found this acting coach and they took me under their wing. I looked for that. I just could never find that person. I would giggle during... But were you doing standup at the time? No, I was trying to just go to acting classes and I would do plays and churches. I mean, just low end stuff. And then I met someone and she told me, you know, have you ever
你是跟迈尔斯和鲍比·蒂斯代尔一起搬过去的吗？事情是这样的吗？你搬到纽约最初是为了当个单口喜剧演员，仅仅是单口喜剧演员还是演员？不，我搬到纽约是为了尝试进入演艺圈，你知道的，你会读到那些报道，哦，我找到了这个表演教练，他们对我很照顾。我一直在找那样的人。我只是从来没找到过那样的人。我在……的时候会咯咯笑。但你当时在说单口喜剧吗？不，我只是试图去上表演课，我会在教堂里演话剧。我的意思是，就是那种低端的东西。然后我遇到了一个人，她告诉我，你有没有。
tried standup, which was always in the back of my mind. And then I did it. And then I kind of got as soon as I did it, I knew that was kind of the path that I felt most comfortable with. I mean, being from where I was from, you just didn't know how to try to figure that out. So I just moved to New York to try to figure out... Where are you from originally? Paris. That's great. You really work on your accent. Paris.
试过单口喜剧？其实这想法一直留在我脑海深处。然后我试了。然后我有点——一旦我尝试了，我就知道那是我感觉最自在的道路。我的意思是，以我的出身背景，你根本不知道该怎么去弄懂这一切。所以我只是搬到了纽约，想搞清楚……你原本是哪里人？巴黎。太棒了。你真的很注重练习口音。巴黎。
It's amazing. I'm from Paris. Paris, California. Paris, Ontario. Paris, Epcot Center. If you go left, just when you get in... You think you're right at Barcelona and you're right at Paris. You grab a churro and before you know it, you're in the middle of Paris. What was it
太神奇了。我来自巴黎。加利福尼亚州的巴黎。安大略省的巴黎。艾特科特中心的巴黎。如果你往左拐，就在你刚进去的时候……你以为你到了巴塞罗那，结果却到了巴黎。你拿根吉事果，不知不觉中，你就身处巴黎市中心了。到底是什么。
about the standup thing where you go, oh, this is it. This is comfy. Were you killing it or was it the opposite? Was it like crickets, but you kind of liked the terror of that? The first time I did it, I did well and I got the bug. And then the next several hundred times I did it, I didn't do that well. So I think I'd already been kind of got addicted to the high right away. And I was not having luck in the acting realm, meaning I remember acting teachers telling me, this is no place for you to do your skits. Because that was one of the reviews of my acting, I remember. So I mean, you remember Uda Hagan, the HB studios in New York.
关于单口喜剧的那种感觉让你觉得，哦，就是这个。这让人觉得很舒服。你是场场炸场还是恰恰相反？是不是冷场了，但你有点喜欢那种让人发指的恐怖感？我第一次登台时表现得很好，然后就上了瘾。接下来几百次登台，我表现得就没那么好了。所以我猜我当时就已经对那种兴奋感上瘾了。而且我在演艺圈一直不太走运，我的意思是，我记得表演老师对我说过，这里可不是让你表演滑稽小品的地方。因为那是我对表演的评价之一，我至今记得。所以我的意思是，你还记得尤达·哈根（Uda Hagan），纽约的 HB 工作室吗？
Do you ever heard of HB studios? So I took classes there and didn't do well. And then standup just was kind of the thing. But yeah, I moved to New York with AD Miles and Bobby Tiz though. So then it was the standup experience and that sort of flavor of comedy that you were doing there that was succeeding that you thought, oh, well, this is something I really feel comfortable with this, this brand of humor, this sort of take on humor. And then taking that into your characters with acting, do you think made you overcome some of the naysayers like Uda Hagan and all of that, that class? Is that what gave you the confidence?
你听说过 HB 工作室吗？我在那儿上过课，表现得并不好。然后单口喜剧就成了那么回事。但是，是的，我和 AD·迈尔斯以及鲍比·蒂斯代尔一起搬到了纽约。所以那时的单口喜剧经历，以及你在那里所做的那种幽默风格获得了成功，让你觉得，哦，好吧，这正是我真正感到自在的领域，这种幽默风格，这种对幽默的看法。然后把它带入你演的角色中，你觉得这让你克服了一些唱反调的人，比如尤达·哈根和所有那些培训班的人吗？这就是给你自信的原因吗？
I think I realized that was more comfortable around comedic persons versus serious actor types. Yeah, that makes sense. But like, like when I first met you, you were kind of, I met you through Miles and you were kind of really doing a lot of standup. And then like kind of, then you did the show that Jason mentioned, that late world. But then you were also pretty immediately, didn't you do a one hour drama on Fox for a while? And then you kind of kept shifting, but standup was always something that you did. Like they were both happening at the same time is my point. Is that right? Does that seem, is that accurate?
我想我意识到自己在喜剧演员身边比在严肃演员类型身边更自在。是的，这说得通。但就像，就像我第一次见你的时候，你有点，我是通过迈尔斯认识你的，你当时真的在做很多单口喜剧。然后就像，接着你做了杰森提到的那个节目，那个《深夜世界》。但随后你也立刻——你难道没有在福克斯电视台演过一小时的正剧吗？然后你一直在转型，但单口喜剧一直是你一直在做的事。我的意思是，这两件事是同时发生的。是这样吗？这准确吗？
Yeah, I mean, I got lucky because I started getting acting jobs. I mean, and I got those acting jobs, not because I was a, I was a terrible auditioner, but I would always comment on the audition process while I was, because I remember when I tested for that Fox show, I remember I would write on the back of my sides. So you would flip the page, right? Of the sides that I've written on the back of the sides. I sure am doing well. Okay, so for the listener, the sides are your pages that you hold during an audition. But Zach, do you have like a really hilarious audition story? I mean, everybody's got one. We just, he just told one. Yeah. Okay. Well, I meant like, did you pass out
是的，我的意思是，我很幸运，因为我开始接到表演工作。我的意思是，我能得到那些表演工作，并不是因为我——我的试镜表现糟糕透顶，但我总是会在试镜过程中对试镜流程评头论足，因为我记得当我为福克斯的那部剧试镜时，我会在台词纸的背面写字。所以你会把剧本翻过来，对吧？在我写过字的剧本背后的台词纸。我表现得可真好。好吧，对于听众朋友来说，剧本纸就是你在试镜时拿在手里的纸。但是，扎克，你有没有什么特别搞笑的试镜故事？我的意思是，每个人都有一个。我们刚刚——他刚刚讲了一个。对。好吧，我的意思是，你有没有晕过去？
real quick? It was just like a general. I thought maybe like a general. Sorry, Zach. But the first time I ever got a laugh in an audition was the first time I auditioned for a drama and they were laughing. They were laughing at me. Okay. And you know, it's one of the situations where did you push through? No, there were 17 people in the room being very judgmental. And I had to play a fighter pilot, you know, in a chair and pretend that it was fighting, you know, top gun style. One hand on the yoke. In the other hand on the script. Yeah. And, and they started giggling. And I can tell they were laughing at me and I stopped my warfare and I looked at them and I said, what's so funny? You put it on
就只是那种常规的。我以为可能是常规的那种。对不起，扎克。但我第一次在试镜中逗笑别人，是我第一次为正剧试镜，他们当时在笑。他们在笑我。好吧。你知道，这就像是一种你硬着头皮坚持下去的情况吗？不，房间里有 17 个人，都在用审视的目光看着我。我得扮演一个战斗机飞行员，你知道的，坐在椅子上，假装在战斗，顶尖枪手（Top Gun）那种风格。一只手放在操纵杆上。另一只手拿着剧本。对。然后，他们开始咯咯笑。我能看出他们是在笑我，我停下了我的空战，看着他们说，有什么好笑的？你把它设为。
autopilot and challenge, but I also had such a chip on my shoulder being from the south. I don't know. I felt, I kind of felt it was me against fancy people. And I had this chip on my shoulder. Well, and I'll bet it hasn't completely gone away to the point where like truly you've won. You've taken yourself out of the rat race. You've got an enormous amount of respect and success in this community for whatever that's worth. Are you in the process of deciding what the hell you want to do with the rest of your life? Or are you happy with what you are doing as far as working when you want on what you want? Or, or you basically retired and you're just going to run these fishing trips? Well, you know, I became such
自动驾驶并接受挑战，但同时我作为一个南方人，也带着一种怀才不遇的怨气。我不知道。我当时觉得这简直是我和那些上流社会的人之间的对决。我带着这种愤世嫉俗的心态。好吧，我敢打赌这种心态并没有完全消失，以至于像你真正赢了一样。你已经退出了名利场的激烈竞争。在这个圈子里，不管这值多少钱，你都赢得了巨大的尊重和成功。你是在决定你余生到底想干什么吗？还是说你对现在的生活很满意，想工作的时候就工作，想做什么就做什么？或者，或者你基本上已经退休了，打算去搞这些钓鱼之旅？好吧，你知道的，我成了那种顾家的好男人，我当爸爸的年纪稍微有点晚，说实话，我深深地爱上了当父亲的感觉。而且我很幸运能处于这样一个位置，在演艺圈的工作方面，我可以把重心放在这上面。听老实话，我一直觉得自己真的很幸运，老实说，如果这一切都停下来了，我还是会觉得，天哪，我得到了一个在演艺圈工作的真正机会，即使它消失了，我也不会困扰，因为我对能够从事这份工作充满了、充满了感激之情。所以这一切就算结束了，我也完全没问题。对。而且你是按照自己想要的方式去做的。你想怎么搞笑就怎么搞笑。你不需要去迎合别人的狗屁标准。我的意思是，你做了。
a family man and I had kids a little later in life and I just fell in love with being a father, to be honest. And I'm lucky enough to be in a position where I can focus on that work as far as show business stuff. Look, I've always thought I was so lucky anyway, honestly, it's never, if it all stopped, I would still go, God, I got a real opportunity to work and show business that even if it went away, it wouldn't bother me because I feel so, so much gratitude towards being able to work anyway. So it could end and I would be fine. Yeah. And you did it the way you wanted to do it. You were funny the way you wanted to be funny. You didn't have to like fit inside someone else's crap. I mean, you've done what
你想做的事，每个人都很欣赏这种独特性。我觉得这绝对是一场巨大的胜利。所以这有点像我最初的问题，那就是——你看上去不像那种野心勃勃的人，会说“我要干这个，我要去参加这个试镜，我要给这个经纪人打电话，我要去……”然后死缠烂打地去追求，你只是对自己忠于自我。你知道吗？他比他表现出来的要更有野心多了。咱们把话挑明了吧。我至今还在第三街步行街（Third Street Promenade）散发传单，为了宣传我的演员头像。我还有一些呢。对，他确实每三个月就拍一次新的演员头像。听着，你得与时俱进。扎克，你提到你在谈论。
you wanted to do and everyone appreciates that uniqueness. I think that's just such a win. So that's kind of what my original question was was like, you don't seem like the ambitious type that's like, I'm going to do this. I'm going to go on this audition. I'm going to call this agent. I'm going to, you know, and go after it where you just kind of stayed true to yourself. And you know what? He's a lot more ambitious than he lets on. Let's just be fucking clear. I still hand out flyers at the third street promenade for, you know, my headshots. I have some of those. Yeah, he does get new headshots every three months. Listen, you got to keep up. Zach, you mentioned that you're talking
父亲的角色，我知道你的家庭对你超级重要，而且你就像所有人一样，你的生活重心完全改变了。就像我们很多人有了孩子之后一样，你也不例外。而且我知道你和你父亲非常亲近，你过去常常跟我讲很多关于你父亲的趣事，你们一起大笑，你们有那么多——你经常谈论扎克，我多年前为迪士尼拍过一部非常棒的电影。《 G 力量》（G-Force）。我极力想忘掉它，而唯一能让我想起它的人就是扎克和我那 12 岁的儿子。哦，我那 9 岁的儿子会提醒你。就是演豚鼠的那部，对吧？对，那部豚鼠电影。但扎克，我记得我们在拍那部电影的时候，你曾跟我讲过这些故事。
about fatherhood and I know that your family is super important to you and you've like everything, your priorities completely shifted. Like for a lot of us, when we have kids and you're no exception. And I know that you were really close to your dad used to tell me the funniest stories about your dad and you guys laughed and you would have so many used to talk about Zach and I did this really great movie for Disney years ago. G force. I tried to forget about and the only person who reminds me of it is Zach and my son who's 12. Oh, my nine year old will remind you of it. The guinea pig one, right? Yeah, the guinea pig movie. But Zach, I remember when we were doing that, you would tell me these stories about
比如你父亲来到片场，他特别喜欢剧组的餐饮服务。哦，他简直不敢相信，我是说——直到短短几年前，他还在问我：“你做这个真的有钱拿吗？”所以你以前经常那样。而且有两件事。一件是，你和你哥哥能轻而易举地把他逗哭，我当时觉得这太搞笑了。另一件是，你和你哥哥会怎么做，或者是你哥哥会怎么做，你们会在办公室里没人的时候进去吗？哦，对。所以我的有时我爸爸并不是最伟大的商人。而且，你知道，我记得去过他的办公室，里面没多少业务在运转。我爸爸会坐在那儿，我和我哥哥就会唱，“没有哪行生意能比这行更好”（There's no business like no business）。然后我父亲会笑得前仰后合。真的太搞笑了。他有着极好的幽默感。
like your dad coming on set and he loved craft service. Oh, he couldn't believe that I was that I mean, until just a few years ago, he still asked me, are you getting paid for what you're doing? So you used to do that. And you there were two things. One was that you guys, you and your brother used to could make him cry really easily, which I was thought was hilarious. And B, the other one was, what would you and your brother do you go or your brother would do you go into his office when it was kind of like dead at the office? Oh yeah. So my dad wasn't the greatest businessman sometimes. And you know, they're I remember just going to his office, there was not a lot of stuff going on. And my dad would be
说实话，这也挺有意思的，说到演艺圈和你的父母，我父亲几年前去世了。对此我很遗憾。这也是我觉得挺诡异的另一件事。我爸爸从我进演艺圈里得到的乐趣，可能比我自己得到的还要多。这样说吧，伙计们。我来自一个小镇。我父亲——你知道他们在电影院里会摆放电影里角色的那种人形立牌，或者诸如此类的纸板立牌吗？对，我爸爸从当地影院拿了一个我的立牌回来，对吧？然后他拿着我的立牌站在街角，向人们挥手，好像在说：“嘿，这是我儿子。”猜我是怎么知道这件事的？这登上了我当地的报纸。所以他是多么支持我。他真的是一个如此美丽的人。我的意思是，他会因为美好而感动落泪。他真的会。他简直就是最温暖的人。我太喜欢你讲的关于你父亲的故事了，而且你总是，你总是笑着，但总是谈论他笑得有多开心，你和你哥哥把他逗得有多开心，这让人感到十分温馨，也是一种极好的联系。我也深有同感。你知道，我猜这有点像，我爸爸在岁数大一点的时候，才稍微理解了我是做什么的以及这有多怪异。但我很喜欢那种。
sitting there and my brother and I would sing, there's no business like no business. And my father would laugh so hard. That's really funny. He had such a great sense of humor. You know, it's interesting too, as far as show business and your parents, my father passed away a couple years ago. And sorry about that. That's the other weird thing about it to me. And my dad got a kick out of me being in show business, probably more than even I did. Put it this way, guys. So I'm from a town, a small town. My father, you know how they'll have cutouts of people in movies in the movie theater of the character or whatever, like a cardboard little stand up things. Yeah, my dad took one from the
他把那个立牌剪下来的想法，作为一个父亲，我完全能感同身受。我绝对也会对我的孩子做出这种事。你知道，你太爱他们了。你只会觉得，而且你根本不在乎。这看起来可能很尴尬，但你根本不在乎。如果这很尴尬，你连两个狗屁都不在乎，对吧？你现在懂了。我的意思是，关于这件事的另一面是，当你变老的时候，也许你们对此也有所感触，天哪，我们确实付出了很多。尽管我们并不是刻意为之，但在我们的潜意识深处总有某种东西。有时候我们真的很想取悦我们的父母。你知道我的意思吗？这种感觉永远不会消失。
local theater of me, right? And he stood on the corner of the street with the cutout of me waving to people as if, Hey, this is my son. Guess how I found out about that? It was in my local paper. So he was so supportive. He was such a beautiful human being. I mean, he cried out of beauty. He just did. He was just the warmest human being. I love the stories that you would tell about your dad and you always and you would laugh, but always talk about how much he laughed, how much you and your brother made him laugh was so endearing and such a great connection. And I get that too. You know, I guess sort of later, it kind of hit my dad a little later in life, what I do and how weird it is. But I love that
我真的很想——我在演艺圈的核心本质，用一种奇怪的方式来说，可能只是因为我喜欢我父亲大笑的声音。我的意思是，听起来虽然很简单，却又有点梦幻，我爸爸和我一起看《本尼·希尔秀》（Benny Hill）或者《全家福》（All in the Family），听着那些笑声。我的意思是，我爸爸看《本尼·希尔秀》时的笑声，就跟他看《全家福》里的政治喜剧时的笑声一模一样。他发出的那种声音，我想我内心深处有一种渴望，想要尽可能多地从人类身上听到那种声音。听起来很老土，但这是真的。同样的桥段也会让你笑吗？你们俩有同样的幽默感吗？
idea that he cut that thing out like that as a father, I can relate to that. Like I would do that to my kid for fucking sure. You know, you just love them so much. You just think like, and you don't give a shit. You know, it could seem embarrassing. You don't, you couldn't give two shits if it's embarrassing, right? You kind of, you get it now. I mean, the other thing about it is when you get older too, and maybe you guys have a connection to this, man, God, we do a lot. Even though we're not trying, there's something deep in our psyche. Sometimes we really want to please our parents. You know what I mean? That never goes away.
我爸爸非常喜欢滑稽的肢体喜剧。那些比较低俗的内容，或者比较偏向脑力思考的内容，我爸爸其实不太感兴趣。所以我不知道。我受各种各样的事情影响更多，但我爸爸有着极好的幽默感，而且他非常非常快活。所以你想逗他笑。我也懂这个。我想我现在意识到我和我父亲之间的联系是，如果我能把我爸爸逗笑，那是如此真实——你没法假装。你一眼就能看出一个人是不是真的在笑，如果我能以一种真正的方式把我爸爸逗笑，并以那种方式与他建立联系，这就好比是一种真正的情感联系，只要他们真心投入。所以我理解这一点。那是非常非常……肖恩，你也能听到你父亲的笑声，但那声音听起来就像是在车里渐渐远去，你知道我的意思吗？对，他真的很温柔。也许还伴随着一个从窗户扔出去的酒瓶。哦，肖恩，我不知道这个故事，但是……这很温馨。
I really want to just the core of me being in show business in a weird way is probably because I loved the sound of my dad's laughing. I mean, as simple as that sounds and is kind of dreamy and my dad watching Benny Hill or all in the family with my father and listening to those laughs. I mean, my dad would laugh at Benny Hill just like he would laugh at political comedy all in the family. That noise that he would make, I think there was a craving for me to hear that kind of noise out of human beings for as much as I could get it. It sounds very corny, but it's true. Does the same stuff make you laugh that made him laugh? Do you guys share the same sense
在我五岁的时候他就离开了。所以这跟你的经历太像了。但听起来你父亲喜欢当观众，而你喜欢当表演者。从这个意义上说，你在你的孩子面前扮演什么角色？你是两者兼而有之吗？我在孩子们面前可不是表演者。我绝对是观众。他们现在还不知道我那一面呢。事实上，他们才四岁和七岁。前天晚上我正把我的小儿子塞进被窝里，我不知道他知不知道我是靠什么谋生的，但他突然说：“嘿，爸爸，”——他有一口奇怪的口音——“嘿，爸爸，你在电影里见过希特勒吗？”
of humor? My dad was very into physical comedy. The kind of dirtier stuff or the more kind of cerebral stuff my dad wasn't much into. So I don't know. I've got more influenced by all kinds of stuff, but my dad had a great sense of humor and he was very, very jovial. So you wanted to make him laugh. I also get that too. I think that I realize now that the connection that I had with my dad was if I could make my dad laugh, that was such a real, you can't fake it. You know if somebody's not really laughing and if I can make my dad laugh in a real way and connect
不会吧。希特勒。他说：“对，你见过希特勒吗？”我说：“没有。”他接着说——中间停顿了很长时间——“他是个挺奇怪的人。”哦，我太喜欢你们在那儿搞的在家自学了。在家自学。你们现在刚好学到世界历史这部分吗？我的小儿子——我是说，他们俩都有这种特质，我觉得孩子们天生就很有幽默感，但我小儿子身上有一种独特的劲儿，我觉得他年纪轻轻就已经开始创作笑话了。
with him in that way, that's like a real emotional connection if they sort of commit. So I understand that. That's something that's very, very... Sean, you could hear your dad laugh too, but in the sound of as it's kind of fading away in a car, you know what I mean? Yeah, he was real sweet. Maybe a bottle being thrown out the window. Oh, Sean, I don't know the story, but... It's uplifting.
同样是前天晚上我把他塞进被窝里。我太太进来了，他说：“嘿，嘿，爸爸，你见过戈林吗？赫尔曼·戈林。”天哪。你有机会和戈培尔一起鬼混过吗？然后我太太进来跟她的小儿子说晚安，我小儿子就说：“嘿，妈妈，别打扰我们。我和爸爸有话要说。”然后她说：“好吧，”她转过身准备离开，结果他说：“我喜欢你的后脑勺。”哇。
He left when I was five. So it's just so similar to yours. But it sounded like your dad loved to be the audience while you loved to be the performer. And in that sense, who are you to your kids? Or are you a little bit of both? I'm not the performer in front of my kids. I am the audience for sure. They don't know that side of me yet. As a matter of fact, four and seven. My youngest son the other night was tucking him in bed and I don't know if he knows what I do for a living, but he goes, hey, dad, he's got a weird accent. Hey, dad, have you ever met Hitler in a movie?
对吧？这真是一个相当不错的笑话。哇。对。这真是一个挺棒的笑话。所以，扎克，扎克，我正想说这个。所以你做了所有这些事情，然后你有点在琢磨接下来会发生什么——就像其他人一样，就像你刚才暗示的那样——你有时接不到工作，有时又能接到，我们都知道这是怎么回事。尤其是早期的。
No way. Hitler. He goes, yeah, you ever met Hitler? I go, no. He goes, he's a long pause. He goes, he's a pretty weird guy. Oh, I love that homeschooling you're doing up there. Homeschooling. You guys are just into world history right about now? My youngest son, I mean, they both have this, you know, kids are funny, I think naturally, but my youngest one has this way about him that I think he's writing jokes very early
时候，你得想方设法付账单。有什么机会你就做什么，然后机会就来了。我刚才已经提到了，我们是在拍那部儿童电影时认识的。然后突然之间，在 2008、2009 年左右，你拍了《宿醉》，这几乎改变了一切。你的生活可以说是发生了巨变。很多人其实已经认识你了，你是一个非常受欢迎的单口喜剧演员，也相当知名，但《宿醉》把一切都推向了另一个高度。说实话，那段经历是怎样的？你是如何注意到生活中的这种转变的？
in life. Again, I'm tucking him in bed the other night. My wife comes in and he says, hey, hey, dad, do you ever meet Goring Harman Goring? Jesus. Did you ever get a chance to pal around with gobbles? So my wife comes in to say goodnight to her youngest son and my youngest son goes, hey, mom, leave us alone. It's just me and daddy want to talk. And she goes, okay, and she turns around to leave and he goes, I like the back of your head. Wow.
好吧，就我们在拍那部电影的时候而言，我记得我们在吃晚饭，我对那几位说：“嘿，这部电影感觉挺不错的。”我以前在我参与过的任何作品中从没过这种感觉。所以在《 G 力量》里没有？哦，天哪，我永远不会忘记在《 G 力量》里的日子。我已经对着冰棍棒工作了三个星期了。没错。就在绿幕旁边。然后威尔来了，你知道的，红人威尔来上班了。
Right? That's a pretty great joke. Wow. Yeah. It's a pretty great joke. So Zach, Zach, I was just going to say this. So you do all this stuff and then you kind of figuring out what's going to, like everybody else, like you kind of alluded to, like you're not getting work and then you are, and we all know how this is. And especially early
我好心提醒威尔一声。作为一个警告，千万别抖你的那些包袱，因为这些人根本没有幽默感。他们绝不会喜欢的。结果不到五分钟，他就把所有人都拿捏得死死的。所有人都被威尔的话逗得哈哈大笑。而我在整整三个星期里都无法让他们笑出来。你当时还以为是观众的问题。我明白了。全都是我自己的问题。全都是我自己的问题。我当时应该当扎克的经纪人的。我来到片场时，我们正在市中心拍戏，他居然骑着自行车去洛杉矶市中心某个狗屎不如的酒店，我就说：“老兄，你在干吗？”
on, you're kind of, you're trying to pay the bills. You do what you can and stuff comes along and I already mentioned we met doing that, this thing, this kids movie. And then all of a sudden you do, what is it, 2008, 2009, you do the hangover and it kind of changes everything. Your life kind of changes. A lot of people know who you are already and you're very popular stand up and you're quite well known, but the hangover kind of takes everything to a different level. Truly what was that experience like? How did you notice that shift in your life?
现在我想想，不，不，不，你得换酒店。还记得我让你搬到我住的地方去吗？你还记得吗？没错。我就说：“你不能这样。你得对自己好一点。他们得对你好一点。”没错。他们在那部电影里还给我提供了提词器。哦，不。哦，你在背台词时很挣扎吗？你在《 G 力量》里有很多长篇独白吗？
Well, as far as when we were filming the movie, I remember we were at dinner and I said to those guys, hey, this movie seems pretty good. And I've never had that feeling before in anything I've worked on. So not on G-Force? Oh God, I'll never forget on G-Force. I'd already been working talking to Popsicle Sticks for three weeks. Sure. Next to a green screen. And Will comes in, you know, Will comes in to work, hotshot Will,
好吧，那些台词根本毫无逻辑。当然，我知道。那是一部奇幻的儿童电影，台词其实并不重要，而且我也记不住那些根本……不重要的台词。对。没错。当你对着一只仓鼠说话时，你很难把各种想法串联起来。你知道的，杰森，你得明白，扎克和我直到后来才发现，这是。
and I tell Will a good look. Just as a warning, don't do any of your bits because these people, they have no sense of the humor. They're just not going to like it. Within five minutes, he had everyone eating out of his hand. Everyone dying laughing at what Will was saying. And I could not get them to laugh for three weeks. You thought it was a problem with the audience. I got it. It was all me. It was all me. I should have been Zach's agent. I come in and we're working downtown and he's like riding his bike to some shit-hole hotel in downtown LA and I'm like, dude, what are you
真的。导演有一天晚上告诉我们，我想，他说，好吧，我们当时问：“你们是怎么想出这部电影的创意的？”他说这是他九岁儿子的创意，这是他九岁儿子的主意。然后我们就想，哦，太棒了，我们正在拍一部由九岁小孩写的电影。我很想看看扎克的儿子带着另一个小孩去推销续集。也许那几只仓鼠拯救了东欧。当然。我的儿子们绝对不会靠近演艺圈半步。你们明白我的意思吗？
doing? Now I go, no, no, no, you're moving hotels. Remember I got you moved to where I was staying? Do you remember that? That's right. I was like, you can't. You got to treat yourself better. They got to treat you better. That's right. And they offered me a teleprompter on that movie. Oh, no. Oh, were you struggling? Were there a lot of monologues for you on GeForce?
不。哇。画风突变。贝特曼这是要盯上他了。贝特曼这是要冲他来了。所以等等，所以扎克，所以扎克，你拍了那部电影，你做了所有这些事，然后你开始拍《宿醉》，你对伙计们说，这感觉不一样了。对。所以我当时隐约觉得这部电影似乎——倒不是说它会大红大紫，但它会是一部既好笑又挺新鲜的作品。但后来电影上映了，似乎更多的人能认出你的脸了，这确实是一种需要去适应的奇妙状况，因为。
Well, none of it made sense. Sure, I know. It was a fantastical kids movie that didn't, the dialogue didn't really matter and I can't memorize things that aren't... That don't matter. Right. Yeah. When you're talking to a hamster, it's hard to link thoughts together. You know, Jason, you have to understand, Zach and I found out late in the game, this is
这是一种不对称的人际关系。如果你本来就已经认清了自我——因为我当时是个年纪稍大的老油条了，你知道的，而且我不太适应出名这回事，回过头来看，我对当时自己表现得那么不适应甚至有点感到尴尬。我当时觉得这对我构成了威胁。它怎么就对你构成威胁了？好吧，首先，我的观点是，名人文化里根本没有什么文化，对吧？所以我一开始就很清楚这一点，而那种对它的崇拜和狂热，正是我们最终选出了威尔最喜欢的那个总统的原因。所以你给他投了四次票。
true. The director told us one night, I think, he said, well, yeah, we were like, how did you come up with the idea for this movie? And he said that his like nine-year-old son, it was his nine-year-old son's idea. And then we're like, oh, great, we're doing a movie that was written by a nine-year-old. I'd love to see Zach's son pitch out with the sequel with the other kid. Maybe the hamsters save Eastern Europe. Sure. My sons will go nowhere near show business. You understand me?
真奇怪。其中有没有什么事让你觉得，哦，其实这也不赖？比如，你能在一家你一直想去但去不了的餐厅订到位子吗？你有没有跟某位你一直很崇拜的人有过短暂的交流，而且你不需要——他们主动想跟你聊天？有些人会从这其中发现某些好处，当然还有钱以及诸如此类的烂事。但其中有没有什么事让你觉得，“哦，如果仅仅是这样，那就太棒了”？你知道的，我现在对这一切都非常感激，因为这是一段非常令人兴奋的经历。但隐私问题，你知道的，这才是唯一让人扫兴的地方，而且我本身也不是那种喜欢去餐厅坐好位置、做那种事的人。对。没错。所以这只是一种转变。这只是一种转变。而且人们也以为我就是那个角色。对。或者期待你无时无刻不在搞笑。对。而且还期待我是一个狂野疯狂的家伙。我其实并不是——我的意思是，我过去可能有点疯狂，但我并不是那样的人。所以这需要一个适应过程。但现在，就像我说的，我对于自己当时居然对此感到愤怒，感到有点不好意思。但这完全可以理解，因为它把你的舒适区给打破了。如果你不是，
No. Wow. It took a turn. Bateman's gunning for him. Bateman's gunning for him. So wait, so Zach, so Zach, so you do the movie, you do all this stuff, and then you start doing the hangover and you say to the guys, this feels different. Yeah. So I kind of felt that this seemed, not that it would be big, but it would be something that was funny and kind of fresh. But then the movie came out and it seemed more people can recognize your face and that that's an interesting thing to navigate because
如果你本身不是个爱出风头的人，如果你天生就不喜欢成为舞台的中心，那么这种成名立刻就是一种强加的负担，因为你失去了匿名性。你无法在人群中隐身。你无法只是——我觉得杰森，大多数人会认为，如果你是个演员，你只有一种类型，对吧？那就是成为注意力的焦点，也就是，你知道的，而我们中的许多人根本不是那样的人。这其中是有区别的。对。但，但这不仅仅是舞台中心的问题。我的意思是，你想表演，你是一个表演者。
it's an asymmetrical relationship. And if you know who you are already, because I was an older dude, you know, and I wasn't too good with being known stuff and looking back, I'm kind of embarrassed by how I was not good with it. I was threatened by it, I think. How are you threatened by it? Well, first of all, I'm of the mind, there is no culture in celebrity culture, right? So I already know that going in and that whole idea of it in the worship of it is why we ended up with that, you know, Will's favorite president. So you voted for him four times.
而且你，但你想在符合你条件的、你所掌控的环境下进行表演，在你掌控的范围内。但当你步行回家，走去商店，或者做任何别的事情时，那不应该算数。感觉那根本不是协议的一部分。就像，嘿，他妈的，等一下。这不在交易范围之内啊。不幸的是，一旦你达到了某种地位，这就是交易。这就是交易。但是你不能——你到了这个时候必须明白，每个人都会识字，都有电视、互联网和社交媒体，你知道的，当你进入这个行业时，这就是交易的一部分。你不可能不知道这一点。
Weird. Was there anything about it that you were like, oh, well, actually, this is not bad. Like, could you get a table at a restaurant you always wanted to get into? Did you, did you have a quick conversation with somebody who you admired and you didn't have to, and they wanted to talk to you? Like, some people find certain things about it, obviously the money and all that kind of crap. But was there anything about it that you were like, oh, if it was just this, that would be great. You know, I'm pretty grateful for it all now because it was such a, it was an exciting thing to go through. But the privacy thing is, you know, that's the only bummer of it
是的。对，没错。但你无法控制你将获得的曝光率和知名度。你知道，扎克当时觉得自己正身处一部非常棒的电影中。他根本不知道这会成为一部巨大的商业大片，还是会扑街。事实证明它是，这意味着他失去了匿名性，而且你——看起来你整个表演的诉求，你喜欢做的事情，带有一种非常民主的平等主义色彩。当你在台上表演单口喜剧时，你是和观众们打成一片的。你不是站在上面居高临下地告诉他们什么才叫好笑。
is, and I'm not really one to go to restaurants and get a nice table and do that anyway. Right. Yeah. So it was a shift. It was just a shift. And people also thought I was that character. Right. Or expecting you to be funny all the time. Yeah. And to be a wild and crazy dude. And I'm not, I mean, I have been in the past a bit, but I'm not like that. So it was just a process. But now it's, like I said, I'm a little embarrassed how I kind of was angry at that. But it's understandable because it pushes you out of your, your comfort. If you're not,
是啊，而且我本来就不是那种会去餐厅订个好桌子享受的人。对吧。是的。所以这是一种转变。这只是一种转变。而且人们也以为我就是那个角色。对吧。或者期望你一直都那么搞笑。是的。还要像个疯狂的家伙。但我不是，我的意思是，过去可能有点儿，但我根本不是那样。所以这只是一个过程。但现在，就像我说的，我有点不好意思自己当时怎么会对此感到愤怒。但这也可以理解，因为它把你推出了舒适区。如果你不是，
if you're not naturally a ham, if you don't naturally are attracted to the center of the stage, then it is immediately an imposition because you, you, you lose your anonymity. You can't disappear in a crowd. You can't just, I think Jason that most people think if you're an actor, you want, there's only one type of actor, right? Which is the center of attention, which is, you know, and, and a lot of us are just not that. And there is a difference. Yeah. But, but it's not just the center of the stage. I mean, you want to do, you are a performer
如果你天生不是那种表现欲强、不喜欢自然而然成为舞台中心的人，那么这立刻就会变成一种强加的负担，因为你失去了匿名性。你无法在人群中隐形。你不能只是……杰森，我想大多数人会觉得，如果你是个演员，你就会想要……演员其实只有一种类型，对吧？那就是成为关注的焦点，你知道的，但我们当中很多人其实并不是那样。这确实有区别。是的。但是，这不仅仅是舞台中心的问题。我的意思是，你想去表演，你是一个表演者，
and you, but, but you want to do it under the conditions that are, you know, that you control, that you control, but when you walk home and you're walking to the store or you're doing whatever that, that shouldn't count. It feels like that that's part of the agreement. Like, Hey, fuck, hang on a second. This wasn't part of the deal. And unfortunately, once you get to a certain place, it is the deal. It is the deal. And, but you can't, you can't, you have to know at this point, everybody can read and has a TV and the internet and the social media that you, you know, that's part of the deal when you get into it. You can't not know that.
而且你……但是你希望在你知道的那种你能够掌控的条件下进行，由你来掌控。但当你步行回家，去商店或者做别的事情时，那本不应该算数。感觉那并不在协议之内。就像是，嘿，操，等等。这可不在交易范围内。但不幸的是，一旦你达到了某种地位，这就是交易的一部分了。这就是交易。而且，你不能……在这个时代，你必须明白，每个人都会识字，都有电视、互联网和社交媒体，你知道的，当你进入这行时，这就是交易的一部分。你不可能不知道这一点。
Yeah. Right. Yeah, that's right. But you can't control the level of exposure and notoriety that you're going to get. You know, Zach felt like he was in the middle of a really good movie. He had no idea whether it was going to be a huge commercial success or not. The fact that it was meant he lost his anonymity and you're, it seems like your whole performance draw, what you'd like to do, it has a very sort of democratic equality type of thing. And when you're on stage doing stand up, you're, you're with the people. You're not up there telling them what's funny.
是的。没错。是的，就是这样。但你无法控制你将获得的曝光度和知名度。扎克当时觉得自己好像正身处一部非常棒的电影中。他根本不知道这部电影是否会获得巨大的商业成功。事实是它成功了，这意味着他失去了匿名性。而你，看起来你所有的表演风格、你喜欢做的事，带有一种非常民主、平等的感觉。当你在台上说单口喜剧时，你是和观众在一起的。你不是站在上面告诉他们什么才叫好笑。
You're kind of, it seems like you're in, there's a, there's an equality with, with your, with your presence with, with the audience as opposed to I am above you almost literally and figuratively giving you comedy and you better laugh at it. So yeah, that's more of a confidence thing that I've never felt comfortable with even knowing what I'm talking about in any situation. But going back to the kind of being known thing, the other thing is that I always make a joke that, you know, nobody walks up to me that has a doctor smock on it. It's always somebody with a who farted t-shirt, you know, but it's also the interaction that I get is probably different interaction than, you know, a lot of actor types get, which is, this is
你有点……好像你处于一种，你和观众之间有一种平等感，而不是字面和精神上我都高高在上地逗你笑，你最好给我笑的那种感觉。所以，这更多是一种自信，无论在什么情况下，我都从来没有在甚至知道自己在说什么的时候感到自在过。但回到那种出名的事情上来，另一件事是，我总是开玩笑说，你知道的，从来没有穿着医生白大褂的人朝我走过来。永远都是穿着一件印着“谁放屁了”的T恤的人，你知道的，但我得到的互动可能也和很多演员类型的同行得到的互动不同，那就是，这是
all true. I mean, I've had people come up to me and go, I'm so sorry to say this, but has anyone ever told you you look like Zach Galifianakis? That's apologies first. I love how they try to solve it for, I'm so sorry. So Zach, I'm going to ask you the question that Sean usually asks, and I'm going to take it out of Sean's corner, which is, you know, you're up there, you're up living up in the woods and you're kind of doing it your way. And it's great. But what now? Like, what do you want to do? Like, what is, what would be, what would make you happy? What's the perfect balance? Like, if you could call the shot, you kind of can, what would you do? Like,
千真万确的。我的意思是，曾有人走到我面前对我说：“我很抱歉这么说，但有没有人说过你长得像扎克·加利费安纳基斯？”先道歉再说。我喜欢他们试图用这种方式来化解尴尬，“真不好意思”。所以，扎克，我要问你一个肖恩通常会问的问题，我要抢在肖恩前面问，就是，你知道的，你待在那儿，你住在树林里，你有点在按自己的方式生活。这很棒。但接下来呢？比如说，你想做什么？比如说，什么会是……什么会让你高兴？完美的平衡是什么？如果你能作主的话——你某种程度上也确实能作主——你会做什么？比如说，
what do you want to do? How do you see the next 10 years playing out for you? You mean, you mean as far as showbiz work? Work and life. Work and life. Life, I've got figured out. Meaning, I'd love to live in Greece for a while. I'd love to go live in Greece. That's the goal of mine. Do you enjoy still being an actor and being in the business and working and all that, or are you just kind of like, it's a hobby now? You know what I mean? Like, some people
你想做什么？你觉得你未来10年的人生会是怎么样的？你是说，你是说就演艺圈的工作而言吗？工作和生活。工作和生活。生活，我已经想明白了。意思是，我很想去希腊住一段时间。我很想去希腊生活。那是我的目标。你还喜欢当演员、在这个圈子里工作以及所有这些吗？还是说你现在觉得这只是一种业余爱好？你知道我的意思吗？就像有些人
reached that point where they're like, you know, I've worked my ass off. I've, I've made my, I stake my claim and, and now I don't have the fire in the belly as much, or maybe you do. Well, I think to me, Sean, it's, I've always been kind of, or of late, I've been mystified by the, I don't know if it's an American thing of wanting more and more and more. You know what I mean? And like I said earlier, look, Jesus, you're not even Canadian yet. Just cool it. All right. Well, you will never be accepted in America.
达到了那种境界，他们会想，你知道的，我曾拼命工作过。我曾经……我已经确立了自己的地位，现在我没有那么多雄心壮志了，或者也许你还有？嗯，我觉得对我来说，肖恩，我一直对那种……或者最近，我对那种——我不知道这算不算是一种美国式的渴望——想要越来越多、越来越多、越来越多的心态感到迷惑。你知道我的意思吗？就像我刚才说的，听着，老天，你甚至还不是加拿大人呢。冷静点吧。好吧，你在美国永远不会被接纳的。
I was with Zach when I, when I became an American citizen, he goes, you'll never be American. Never. Never. So go worship that queen, whatever it is you Canadians are into. Wait, you live there. Now you're shitting on it. Do you have Canadian citizenship? No, it's actually kind of difficult to, to do it. It's not as easy as you would think. Canada is pretty strict with that. So, so as far as the life to work ratio, the next 10 years would look just like the last
我和扎克在一起时，当我……当我成为美国公民时，他说：“你永远不会成为美国人。永远不会。永远不会。”所以去崇拜那个女王吧，不管你们加拿大人迷恋的是什么。等等，你住在那儿。现在你又在贬低它了。你有加拿大公民身份吗？没有，其实要拿到还挺难的，没你想的那么容易。加拿大在这方面相当严格。所以，就生活与工作的比例而言，接下来的10年看起来会和过去
10 years. That's a, that's a comfortable balance. I think for me, I mean, look, I'm real lucky. I would like to continue working here and there and show business. If I'm, I mean, stand up to me. I can never not do. I love it too much. It just is such a therapy, if you will, for me in a weird way. But honestly, I just really love to garden. I love to be in the garden. And I, I, I think about shows that maybe I'd like to develop. I'm working on something in my head about a show that's kind of like the between two ferns element, but not the same character, but some, it's kind of a low end show like that.
10年差不多。这是一个……这是一个舒适的平衡。我觉得对我来说，听着，我真的很幸运。我很想在演艺圈里断断续续地继续工作。如果我是指……单口喜剧对我来说，我是永远无法不做的。我太爱它了。用奇怪的方式来说，它对我来说简直就像是一种疗愈。但老实说，我真的超爱园艺。我喜欢在花园里待着。而且，我……我一直在想一些我可能想开发的节目。我脑子里正在琢磨一个节目，有点像《蕨间笑谈》那种元素，但不是同一个角色，而是某种……有点像那种低成本的节目。
You did baskets as well, right? Like how many seasons did you do on baskets? Four. Four. What was it? It was a great show. Yeah. It was a great show. And you were great in it. Loved you.
你也演过《小丑梦摇篮》，对吧？你在《小丑梦摇篮》里拍了多少季？四季。四季。感觉怎么样？那是一部很棒的剧。对啊。那是一部很棒的剧。而且你在里面演得太棒了。大家都爱你。
What was your schedule? Did you like the way that, did that fit your life doing a show like that? It's a rush. I got so excited every morning when I get up for work and I've always had that with acting. I have always gotten up very eager to go to work. I have to say that. I mean, that part of it is so energetic and I love it. And I actually, I make fun of actors a lot, but I really do love actors. I do. And that whole creative process on baskets and the family, you know, when you work on a show and you like the people around you and you don't want that to end.
你的日程安排是怎样的？你喜欢那种方式吗？演那样一部剧适合你的生活吗？那是一种冲劲。每天早上我起床准备去工作时都兴奋得不得了，我演戏一直都是这样。我一直都是满怀期待地去上班。我必须得说。我的意思是，那部分充满活力，我太爱了。而且其实，我经常取笑演员，但我真的很爱演员。我是认真的。还有在《小丑梦摇篮》以及这个大家庭里的整个创作过程，你知道的，当你参与一部剧，你喜欢周围的人，你就不希望这一切结束。
No, I don't. No, I don't. No. And I've worked with both these guys on shows and I don't fucking know that yet. You're looking at the clock waiting for it to end. So you know that element of it. I mean, I guess, yeah, you guys know how it is. I mean, that part of it is so, we're so lucky to be able to goof off and get, you know, make a living of it. I remember, Jason, do you remember like I drive on a set at like at Fox? This is the most ever had closest to that was driving onto the Fox lot every morning to do a rest
不，我不想。不，我不想。不。而且我和这两位家伙都在节目里合作过，我他妈的还没那种感觉呢。你盯着时钟等着它结束。所以你知道那种感觉。我的意思是，我想，是的，你们知道那是怎样的。我的意思是，那部分太……我们太幸运了，能有机会瞎胡闹还能以此谋生。我记得，杰森，你还记得我开车去片场，比如在福克斯？这最接近的那次经历就是每天早上开车去福克斯的片场去拍《发展受阻》
development and every day like putting my fucking pass on the thing and thinking like, God, I'm so happy. There wasn't a day that I drove on to the lot and thought, Oh man, I got to get through today. Like not one and I, and I missed that because you have those moments now and maybe I'm older and maybe because I look at a lot of things as taking me away from my kids or spending time with the kids. I kind of like sometimes I have a tough time. There's like this kind of adversarial position between my work and my life and I get bummed out sometimes. And so that, you know, if I stay late or whatever, I'm like, you fuckers,
，然后每天就像把我的通行证挂在那个东西上，心里想着：“天哪，我太高兴了。”从来没有哪一天我开车进片场时心想：“噢，天哪，我得熬过今天。”一次也没有，而且我……我很怀念那种感觉，因为你现在也有过那些时刻，也许是因为我老了，也许是因为我觉得很多事情都在占用我陪伴孩子的时间。我有时候觉得挺难的。我的工作和生活之间似乎有一种对立的关系，我有时会觉得很沮丧。所以，你知道的，如果我留得很晚什么的，我就会想：“你们这群混蛋，
I want to be home. You know, I didn't know you were on a rested development. Yeah. He played the older brother, right? Were you the oldest? Well, I'm pretty sure you were the oldest. Who did you used to look up to? Who are the people that you, when you were young, before you moved to New York with Miles and Bobby and the whole thing, like who are the, who
我想回家。”你知道的，我不知道你演过《发展受阻》。对。他演大哥，对吧？你是老大吗？好吧，我很确信你是老大。你以前崇拜谁？当你年轻的时候，在你和迈尔斯、鲍比还有其他人一起搬去纽约之前，谁是你的……
are the people, comedians or actors or performer? I don't know. Just who are your sort of inspirations artistically that you kind of looked at and said, like, I want to do that. Andy Rice. Andy Rice. Andy Rice, sure. Not a lot of people know that she started under Uda Hagan and then went into politics. Well, we were in a improv group together called Mission Improvable. That's how we first met. I was influenced. I mean, Eddie Murphy, Bill Murray, then later in life, you know, it was
谁是那些人，喜剧演员、演员或者表演者？我不知道。谁是你在艺术上的灵感来源，让你看着他们然后说：“我想成为那样的人。”安迪·赖斯。安迪·赖斯。安迪·赖斯，当然。没多少人知道她师从于乌达·哈根，后来才从政的。好吧，我们曾在一个叫“即兴特工”的即兴喜剧团里一起表演。那是我们第一次见面。我深受影响。我是说，埃迪·墨菲、比尔·默瑞，后来在生活中，你知道的，就
kind of more esoteric type of performers. But I, I had to say, and I've told people this, I was more influenced by my cousins and my siblings or my brother and sister were funny people and we would perform a lot. My sister and brother and I would do sketches about the Iran Contra. You know, we would watch the news and try to do sketches for my parents. So I was kind of more influenced by my family, strangely. Based on the hearings, like the Olly North hearings of Iran Contra? No, it was, I remember my sister was dressed as the Ayatollah in my mom's robe and I was a reporter. I can't remember exactly what, but my family always, we were pretty much
更偏向于那种比较深奥类型的表演者。但是，我不得不说——而且我曾对别人说过——我受表兄弟姐妹和兄弟姐妹的影响更大，我的兄弟姐妹都是很有趣的人，我们经常一起表演。我姐姐、哥哥和我经常演一些关于伊朗-反抗军事件的小品。你知道的，我们会看新闻，然后试着为我父母表演小品。所以奇怪的是，我其实受我的家人影响更大。是根据听证会来的吗，比如伊朗-反抗军事件的奥利·诺斯听证会？不，那是……我记得我姐姐穿着我妈妈的长袍装扮成阿亚图拉，而我是一个记者。我记不清具体细节了，但我的家人总是……我们差不多都是
news junkies. But so I, but also you do remember the show, Shields and Yarnel? Of course, always, all the robots. Yeah, I loved it. So I used to copy their sketches when they would do the robot all the time. I did it all the time. By the way, during the pandemic, if somebody comes in, I go, do you have a Shields and Yarnel? I would say that all the time. And people would be like, what are you talking about? Yeah. So they were great. And they were in my Mac. Yeah, for sure.
新闻迷。不过，还有，你也记得那个节目《希尔兹与约内尔》吧？当然，一直都记得，全都是机器人。对，我超喜欢。所以我以前总是模仿他们做机器人的小品。我一直在做这个。顺便说一句，在大流行期间，如果有人进来，我就会说：“你有《希尔兹与约内尔》吗？”我总是这么说。然后人们就会说：“你在说什么呢？”对啊，所以他们太棒了。而且他们就在我的Mac里。对，肯定的。
Okay. So I was hearing all that. So what, I don't know, what was your favorite, like what's your favorite movie of all time? Yeah, all bits aside, hangover three. Yeah. Yeah. Growing up, I know that I'd never really seen anything like Spinal Tap before. When I saw that when I was young, that was pretty because it was, there was a lot of subtlety to it. No winking. That to me was very, that movie to me. And then, Will, I know you and I've talked about it pretentiously is with Nell and I. I mean, I think of people, I think a lot of comedians know it, but I don't know if American movie audiences know, but that
好吧。我听到所有这些。所以，什么……我不知道，你最喜欢的是什么……你这辈子最喜欢的电影是什么？抛开所有段子不谈，《宿醉3》。对。没错。在成长过程中，我知道我从没见过像《我与长发阿公》那样独特的作品。当我年轻时看到那部电影，那真的很……因为里面有很多微妙之处。没有刻意眨眼暗示。对我来说，那部电影……然后，威尔，我知道你和我带着点装腔作势的语气讨论过《我与长发阿公》。我的意思是，我觉得很多人……我想很多喜剧演员都知道它，但我不知道美国观众知不知道，但
to me is Me too. It's the pinnacle. I really got to see that film. I've heard you talk about that film for what, 30 years now, Will. And I've still not seen it. The perfect film. There's not a wasted moment or scene in that movie. It's really a great balance. It's brilliant writing. Zack knows it too. What's it called? With Nail and I, Richard E. Grant, and it was written by and directed by this guy, Bruce Robinson. It's brilliant. Paul McGahn. But it's such a perfect film, isn't it? Because it's funny and it's
对我来说，那是……我也是。那是巅峰。我真的得去看看那部电影。威尔，我听你讨论那部电影有多久了，30年了吧。而我居然还没看过。完美的电影。那部电影里没有浪费任何一个时刻或镜头。这真的是一个极好的平衡。这是绝妙的剧本。扎克也知道。那叫什么名字？《我与长发阿公》，主演是理查德·E·格兰特，编剧和导演是这家伙，布鲁斯·罗宾逊。太精彩了。保罗·麦甘。但它是一部如此完美的电影，不是吗？因为它既搞笑又
really dramatic. It's quite touching and quite moving as well. Quite tragic. I can't believe you guys haven't seen that. I've never heard of it. So, Zack, so you're there. We can't access you because you're so far away, but we want you back. We really, really want you back. How are you going to do, how do you scratch the itch for stand up? Because you talk about it as a thing that like you, once you get it and you're sort of addicted to it, you are so far up there and you're not living in the city. Like, do you have a hankering to get back out and to, and to get out there and perform, not necessarily in films or whatever, acting, but to do stand up? Like, is that
非常戏剧化。它也相当触动人心，令人感动。相当悲剧。真不敢相信你们都没看过。我从来没听说过。所以，扎克，你现在在那儿。我们联系不到你，因为你住得太远了，但我们想让你回来。我们真的、真的想让你回来。你打算怎么做？你怎么去解单口喜剧的戏瘾？因为你把它说得像是一种……一旦你沾上了，就对它上瘾了，你现在离得那么远，又不住在城里。就像，你有没有那种渴望想回到外面去，去……去到外面进行表演，不一定非得是拍电影什么的、演戏，而是去说单口喜剧？就像，这是
something you're sort of chomping at the bit to do? Yeah, a bit. I mean, I had this craving the other night that I really needed to kind of try to see if some of the things I've written down would work, even work. For some standups, at least for me, it's not like riding a bike. You need to get your legs again, rhythm, and this is obviously the longest hiatus for so many comics. It'll be interesting to see how much rustiness there will be from comics, or if there was going to be this huge explosion of people just wanting to express themselves and there's going to be a whole brand of, you know, humor that's come out, born out of this, who knows. But yeah, I feel, I feel
你有点渴望去做的吗？对，有一点。我是说，前几天我突然有一种强烈的渴望，真的很想去试一试，看看我写下来的那些东西能不能行，甚至能不能逗笑。对于某些单口喜剧演员来说，至少对我而言，这不像骑自行车。你需要重新找回状态、节奏，这显然是许多喜剧演员经历过的最漫长的停工期。看看喜剧演员身上还会有多少生疏感，或者是否会迎来一波人们渴望表达自我的巨大爆发，并且会由此诞生出一整派……你知道的，从这当中孕育出的幽默风格，谁知道呢。但，是的，我觉得……
I would like to get on stage. But you, you know, it's, it's funny you talk about getting, getting your city likes back because you kind of had this really cool device. You use music and obviously you're very musical and you play piano and you would use piano sometimes in, as part of your act, right? You sort of play a little bit of piano between jokes. That's one of the funniest things I've ever seen. Of course, it's a hilarious bit, but also it must have been really kind of comforting in a certain way, right? Cause there was no gaps.
我很想登上舞台。但是，你知道的，你谈到找回城市演出的感觉时很有意思，因为你以前有一种非常酷的装置。你用音乐，显然你很有音乐细胞，你会弹钢琴，有时会在表演中把钢琴当作你喜剧的一部分，对吧？你在笑话之间会弹一会儿钢琴。那是我见过的最搞笑的事情之一。当然，这是一个极其搞笑的段子，但从某种特定角度来看，它肯定也挺让人安心的，对吧？因为没有任何冷场。
Well, it's a couple of things. So yeah, I started playing piano and by the way, I don't know how to play. I can't read music. I know how to fake melancholy music. And then that melancholy music, juxtaposed to diarrhea jokes is a combination that I don't know if that's really been done. I don't know, but the other part of it is on the road, it became limiting because I would be 20 minutes at the piano telling these one liners and there's only one kind of tone you can do there. So I kind of stopped playing the piano with my act because I just wanted to go explore some other things. The piano is a little limiting that way, especially when you're not musically
嗯，有几个原因。所以，是的，我开始弹钢琴，顺便说一句，我根本不会弹。我不会看谱。我只会弹那种假装忧郁的音乐。然后，把那种忧郁的音乐和腹泻的笑话并置在一起，这种组合我不知道以前有没有人做过。我不知道，但另一方面，在巡演途中，这变得有些局限，因为我会坐在钢琴前20分钟讲这些单行笑话，而那里只有一种情绪基调。所以我后来在表演中不再弹钢琴了，因为我只是想去探索一些别的东西。从这个角度来看，钢琴确实有点局限，特别是当你本来就没什么音乐天赋的时候，而我确实没有。
that inclined, which I'm not. Well, you could have Sean, Sean could come in a company to you because he's a pianist. I just in the background, Sean, are you, are you classically trained? Yeah, I thought that was what I was going to do with my life. I studied it about 25 years, 20 years. No kidding. Yeah. Well, listen, Zach, we've taken it.
好吧，你可以让肖恩……肖恩可以来给你伴奏，因为他是钢琴家。我只是想在背景里问一句，肖恩，你是科班出身吗？对，我以前以为这就是我这一生要从事的事业。我学了大约25年，20年。不是吧。对啊。好吧，听着，扎克，我们已经占用了你……
Go ahead. No, no, go ahead, please. I think you're going to end it. Go, go, go, go. No, I was getting ready to go into another boring thing. You haven't talked to anybody in months. Go ahead, say one more thing. No, this is what I, what I do, I only do podcasts so I can talk to adults. Sorry about that. Were you doing podcasts? Yeah, sure.
说吧。不，不，请说。我想你这是要结束了。说吧，说吧，说吧。不，我正准备扯到另一个无聊的事情上去。你已经好几个月没跟任何人说过话了。说吧，再多说一句。不，这就是我……我做播客的唯一原因就是为了能跟成年人说话。不好意思啊。你一直在做播客吗？当然。
I got a guy, a guy, a guy called me last week and this was weird. I picked up my phone. It was a number I, this is also how lonely I am. I'm answering phone calls. I don't, I don't recognize the number. Okay. Yeah. Hello. This is Zach. Can we talk? And so this guy calls me and he goes, Hey, Mr. Galvanakis, I wanted to know if you'd be on my podcast and I went, who, who, who is this? And he went into this description of who he was, some guy that has a podcast and I go, how did you get my number? And he goes, the white pages. Oh no way.
我上周接到一个家伙的电话，这事挺诡异的。我接了电话。那是一个我……这也是我有多孤独的体现。我连不认识的号码都接电话。好吧。你好，我是扎克。能聊聊吗？然后这个家伙打电话给我，他说：“嗨，加利费安纳基斯先生，我想知道你愿不愿意上我的播客。”然后我说：“你是……你是谁？”接着他开始描述他是谁，某个拥有一个播客的家伙。然后我说：“你是怎么拿到我的电话号码的？”他说：“白页电话簿。”哦，不可能。
The white pages. That doesn't exist anymore, does it? Up there, I guess. He was lying. It was just funny. He cold called me and I mean, I was pleasant to him, but it was weird that he cold called me to be in his podcast. Maybe I should just do it anyway. Got to be pretty funny if you fucking did it. I think I will. Call him back. Can I sign you guys up for it too?
白页电话簿。那早就没有了吧，对吗？住在山上的人或许还有吧。他在撒谎。这只是个玩笑。他给我打了个冷不防的推销电话，我的意思是，我对挺客气的，但他突然打电话来让我上他的播客，这感觉怪怪的。也许我真该随便答应他算了。你要是真他妈去了，那可就太搞笑了。我想我会的。回他电话。我能把你们两个也带上吗？
Yeah, of course. Yeah, that'd be great. Of course. I'll just tell him I can't do it, but I've got Sean Hayes that's dying to do it. I'm in. Well, fuck, Zach, we won't take up any more of your time. Thank you so much. Thanks guys. You're such a prince. Thanks, man.
对，当然。好啊，那太棒了。当然。我只会告诉他我不能去，但我有个极度渴望去的肖恩·海耶斯。算我一个。好吧，他妈的，扎克，我们不再占用你的时间了。非常感谢。谢谢你们，伙计们。你真是个大好人。谢谢你，老兄。
Thanks for having me on. Very nice of you to do this. It's great to see you. And well, we'll talk payment. Yeah, we'll talk payment. We'll talk payment. Email me, email me an invoice, all right? You do e-transfers? Of course.
谢谢邀请我来。你这么做真是太好了。很高兴见到你。而且，我们回头谈报酬。对，我们谈报酬。我们谈报酬。给我发电子邮件，给我发张发票，好吗？你支持电子转账吗？当然。
Yeah. Yeah, but through, we do it through the Caimans. We, we miss you, man. We'd love to see you back in town at some point. You're the fucking best. You're such a great dude and so much love to you and the family. And thanks guys. Thanks for doing this, man. So good to see you Zach. Be well. Thanks Zach.
对。对，不过通过……我们通过开曼群岛转。我们想你，老兄。希望什么时候能在城里见到你。你他妈的太棒了。你是个绝佳的家伙，向你和你的家人致以无限的爱。谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢你们抽出时间，老兄。很高兴见到你，扎克。保重。谢谢你，扎克。
All right. Bye guys. See you buddy. Bye buddy. Gosh, that was so fun having Zach on, right? Out of the, from, from the wilderness. Yeah, that is, I gotta tell you, it's a, it's a real, real fantasy for me. Just kind of, did you guys ever fantasize about just unplugging and just plugging in at another place on the big blue ball? All the time.
好啦，再见，伙计们。回见，兄弟。再见，兄弟。天哪，有扎克来做客太有趣了，对吧？从……从荒野中来。对，我得告诉你，这对我来说简直是个真正的、真正的幻想。那种……你们有没有幻想过直接拔掉电源，然后在这个巨大的蓝色球体上的另一个地方重新插上电源？经常。
And, and just kind of starting over. Yeah, for sure. He, he's so like, I don't know him. Like, I'm gonna, like, I'm gonna obviously, will you know him? But he, he just seems so down to earth and normal and chill and such a great family. And yes. And Jason, to your point, I was like, wow, I envy that, that you could just go up to Canada or whatever country and just kind of check out like that from the business. Yeah. Yeah. He's, he's, you know, he's, I guess, you know, he pointed out, so his wife is Canadian
而且……就当是重新开始。对，绝对是的。他太……我跟他不熟。我的意思是，当然，威尔你认识他。但他看起来是那么地脚踏实地、正常、随性，而且有个那么棒的家庭。没错。而且，杰森，正如你所说，我就在想，天哪，我真羡慕这一点，你能直接搬到加拿大或别的什么国家，然后就这样从这个圈子里隐退。对。对。他……他，你知道的，正如他所指出的，所以他的妻子是个加拿大人，
and obviously as a Canadian, I love how much he embraces Canada and really appreciates not just the wilderness, but kind of Canadian sensibility. And, which is funny because he used to make fun of me for so many years for being Canadian. And then now he's there. And I just, I love it so much. I cherish every time he talks about being Canadian. I'm like, yeah, of course you fucking dummy for years you fucking clowned me and now suck it. And then you know what, maybe I'll have him kicked out. Yeah. Maybe I'll have him kicked out.
而且显而易见，作为加拿大人，我太喜欢他拥抱加拿大、真正欣赏的不仅是那里的荒野，还有那种加拿大的为人处世之道了。这很有趣，因为他曾连续多年取笑我是个加拿大人。而现在他却住在那里。我真的太喜欢了。我珍惜他每一次谈论自己成为加拿大人时的情景，我就会想：“对啊，你这个蠢货，你他妈取笑了我好多年，现在受着吧。”然后你知道吗？也许我会把他驱逐出境。对。也许我会让人把他驱逐出境。
It is so flippin' pretty where he is. It's gorgeous. Oh my God. I've never been to British Columbia. It's so green and all the eagles and the bears and the fish and the, I mean, it's just, it's everything. It's so spectacular. Well, first of all, the air, you know, you get up there in British Columbia and off the coast.
他住的那地方简直美翻了。太绝了。天哪。我从没去过不列颠哥伦比亚省。那里太绿了，还有所有的老鹰、熊和鱼，我的意思是，简直应有尽有。太壮观了。好吧，首先，那个空气，你知道的，你到了不列颠哥伦比亚省那边，靠近海岸的地方。
It's like the valley. It's a little better than the valley. It's kind of like Seami Valley. Yes. Like in the summer. Yes. Yeah. You know what I mean? Like Northridge, really, yeah, it's lush and lush. You're just, you're just ripping off all the hits from the valley.
就像圣费尔南多谷。比山谷稍微好一点。有点像西米谷。对的。就像夏天那样。对的。你知道我的意思吗？就像诺思里奇一样，真的，对，那里郁郁葱葱。你这只是在模仿山谷里的所有梗。
Panorama City. Oh, no, it can't touch Panorama City. That's in a different league. Yeah, you're right. But I love him. I'm such a huge fan. He's so. He's such a unique talent.
全景城。哦，不，那可比不上全景城。那是完全不同的级别。是的，你说得对。但我太喜欢他了。我是他的超级粉丝。他太……他是一个如此独特的才华横溢的人。
Right. Yeah. I mean, he's just like, he's done it all. So dry. So dry. I forgot to ask him about between two ferns. Is that completely done now? He's not doing that anymore.
对。我的意思是，他就像是……他什么都尝试过了。太干瘪幽默了。太干瘪了。我忘了问他关于《蕨间笑谈》的事了。那个节目现在彻底结束了吗？他不再做那个了吗？
Is he? I think that it'll never be done. Is kind of probably. Never be done again. Oh, never be finished. No. Never be finished. Oh, I hope not.
不是吗？我想它大概永远都不会结束了吧。可能吧。再也不会结束了。哦，永远不会结束。不。永远不会结束。哦，希望如此。
Yeah. Something that great that only comes, comes by like every once, once every 200 years. What's that called? Oh, bye. Bye, Antonio. You idiot. Smart. Nice.
对。如此伟大的作品，大概每200年才会出现一次。那叫什么来着？哦，再见。再见，安东尼奥。你个白痴。聪明。好。
Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Nice. Smart. Smart.
聪明。好。聪明。好。聪明。好。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。